(audience chattering)
(audience cheering)
- On behalf of the faculty and staff
of the Yale School of Public Health,
I congratulate the members
of the Class of 2022.
(audience cheering)
We are gathered to
celebrate your achievements
and acknowledge this graduation milestone.
My colleagues and I welcome,
thank, and congratulate all
who played a critical role
in shaping the aspirations
of all our graduates of the
Yale School of Public Health
and contributed to your success.
These special people
extend well beyond Yale,
most notably including
your parents or guardians,
your role models, your
siblings, your grandparents,
your extended family and
friends, and, for some of you,
your spouses or partners
and your children.
We want to thank all of
you who have made possible
the academic and life
journeys of our graduates.
So, families and friends of our graduates,
please accept our heartfelt
gratitude as we pause
to applaud your contributions
to our YSPH graduates.
(audience cheering)
Now, I address our MPH graduates.
The past 30 months have thrust our school
and our discipline of public
health into the spotlight.
As we have striven to overcome
this historic pandemic threat,
our school's faculty have highlighted
the social inequities
that inhibit wellness
in the most vulnerable
members of our population.
These have included the
institutionalized elderly,
our frontline workers, our
health care workers in homes
and longterm care settings,
and clinics and hospitals.
Special efforts are needed
for persons with disabilities,
those with social isolation,
those with housing, food,
or employment insecurity.
All these persons have been highlighted
in your studies, and for many of you,
your experiences as you
studied here in New Haven.
Whether for COVID-19, maternal
mortality, or injuries,
death rates confirm racial,
ethnic, and economic disparities
in both risk and access
to prevention and care.
Our environmental scientists
work on global plastics,
toxins, climate change, and
safe air qualities in buildings.
Our epidemiologists, biostatisticians,
and modelers have worked
to unearth the causes
and solutions of the COVID-19 pandemic
and to forecast its course,
as they have done for TB,
HIV, vector-borne diseases,
and a host of other tropical
and local infections.
Our social and behavioral
scientists have refined
health communications and messaging
for risk reduction and wellness,
also examining the structural
determinants of illness.
Our biologists have helped
discover new diagnostics,
new therapeutics and vaccines,
Unearthed some of the origins
of disease pathogenesis.
Our policy and management
faculty have tackled a myriad
of systemic flaws in our health system,
issues in tobacco and substance use,
and vaccine policy, to name but a few.
Our Office of Public Health Practice,
our Office of Communications,
our Office of Alumni and
Development have striven to engage
our various communities with new vigor,
helping transform our
relevance to our university,
our alumni, our city of New
Haven, our state and region,
and even at national and
international levels.
Our Emerging Infections Program
and our Community Alliance
for Research and Engagement,
that is a full partnership
with Southern Connecticut
State University,
deserve credit for their
massive community service.
Public health is more visible
than ever within society,
and we see the compelling
issues highlighted by media
and policymakers alike as never before.
YSPH students, staff,
and faculty have worked
with nursing homes, school districts,
arts organizations, Yale
alumni, other schools at Yale,
and our partners in low
and middle-income countries
of Africa, Asia, and Latin America.
We've engaged our city and our state,
as well as governments and institutions
in other states including New York,
Rhode Island, even
Kentucky and California.
Our strong community has
been on the forefront
of Yale's response to the pandemic
and continuing our momentum
in the many compelling themes
of health care reform,
informatics and data sciences,
control of chronic and
infectious diseases,
promoting healthy mothers and children,
seeking healthy aging paradigms,
and addressing LGBTQ health,
protecting our environment,
and adapting to change,
just to name a few.
All of you graduating in
2022 have attended YSPH
in a historic moment for
our nation and our world.
Our community embodies boldness of vision,
persistence in the face of obstacles,
and a commitment to public education
and welfare in its health challenges.
The public health workforce,
into which most of you will enter,
works in society's shadows.
After all, a patient assisted by a nurse
or doctor is fully aware of
the benefits that might ensue.
But a community kept safe
by public health insight
and exertion may be quite unaware
of the hazards prevented or mitigated.
In this year of 2022,
you've equipped yourselves
for further study
or for immediate entry
into the health workforce
with skills that the world needs urgently.
I have one hope for all of you,
that is that your career is such
that you wake up on Monday
morning to welcome the work week
for the ability to improve our society
and the world each and every working day.
Despite constraints due to COVID-19,
I hope you leave with
pride in your alma mater,
knowing that your studies
in public health happened
at a truly historic time of challenge
for our university, society,
and global community.
When people ask me about the best part
of my deanship since 2017,
I can say that the passion
of our students, staff,
and faculty have motivated
and invigorated me
to strive to improve our
school and our disciplines.
Meeting our future public
health leaders, all of you,
has enabled me to learn about
your accomplishments,
plans, and aspirations.
While our world has
its immense challenges,
I have a tremendous sense
of optimism for the future
of the field of public
health as we turn the mantle
of leadership over to
you, our new generation.
I speak on behalf of all
the faculty and staff
when I say that we've been
honored to work with you,
guide your education, and learn from you.
It now gives me great pleasure
to introduce Nandini Deo.
Nandini has been chosen by her peers
to deliver this year's student address.
Nandini's passion lies in
community-based trauma prevention.
Prior to her time at YSPH,
she worked in federal and state HIV,
STI, and TB prevention at the CDC,
the Oregon Health Authority
and in the Utah Department
of Health as well.
During her time at YSPH,
Nandini has had the privilege of working
on the border identity stress
team led by Dr. Skyler Jackson
to capture the psychosocial
experiences of individuals
who defy binary identification
across race, gender,
and sexual orientation.
She's also worked under the
guidance of Dr. Keitra Thompson
as a qualitative evaluator
for the MOMS partnership
in the Elevate Policy Lab,
aimed at reducing depressive symptoms
and increasing social
and economic mobility
for low-income mothers.
In addition, Nandini
has served on the board
of Yale's Emerging Majority
Students Association
and as a teaching fellow
for Health Equity & Social Justice
and LGBTQ Population Health.
She looks forward to rejoining
the public health
workforce post-graduation,
with the ultimate goal
of pursuing a doctorate
in clinical or counseling psychology.
It is a an honor and an absolute delight
to invite you to the podium, Nandini Deo,
our 2022 student speaker.
(audience cheering)
(Nandini squeals)
- Thanks, friends. Hi, good afternoon.
I can't believe this
is actually happening.
Amazing.
So writing this graduation speech felt...
Actually, it felt a lot
like graduate school:
Me and my bestie, Google,
against the world.
You can't exactly Google "how
to write a graduation speech
for a class that voluntarily
studied public health
amidst a global pandemic,"
but for what it's worth,
I'll have you know that I did try.
Google said to find a powerful hook,
something compelling, profound even.
So I went to the next place
I knew wouldn't fail me: Academic Twitter.
As expected, I found
myself in a rabbit hole
where I understood about
30% of the vocabulary
and even less of the theory.
And based on this excellent knowledge base
and a vague interpretation
of others' profundity,
here I am in front of you all.
The last speech I wrote began
with a quote from the Dalai Lama,
and this one's from an
organizational psychologist
with an impressive Twitter feed.
So academia has, simply
put, broadened my horizons.
Adam Grant wrote, in
less than 280 characters,
"Too many people spend their
lives being dutiful descendants
instead of good ancestors.
The responsibility of
each generation is not
to please their predecessors,
it's to improve things
for their offspring."
This Tweet actually reminded
me of a conversation
I'd had with a supervisor
in my early years of public health,
who advised that our role
in this field was to water
a garden, consistently,
meticulously, whether or
not we'd ever see it bloom.
It's taken me many more years,
and experiences with you all,
to realize that our garden is
literally the entire world,
and that watering it comes
in many different forms:
from improving water quality
to increasing hygiene
and sanitation in conflict zones,
modeling the impacts of
major health policies,
fundamentally restructuring
our health care systems,
designing sustainability interventions
to ameliorate climate change,
analyzing and triangulating
millions of data points
in an effort to reduce
transmission of disease,
and finding new and creative ways
to motivate belief and behavior change.
Now, more than ever, it is
clear that public health impacts
every system on every
corner of this earth.
It's an exciting realization,
perhaps coupled with big fat overwhelm,
because our careers are
often a labor of love
with the central goal of improving life
for those who may come after us.
In a field so broad, ever-changing,
and, now, highly politicized,
what does it mean to
become a good ancestor?
I'm not gonna pretend like I know
the answer to this question
or that I'm even under the assumption
that there is one answer.
After all, one of the
many things we've learned
at our time here at YSPH is
that there are many truths,
and we will be tasked with
making room for them all.
This program did, however,
train many of us as researchers
who use observation and conversation
to make meaning and consider solutions.
So this my earnest attempt,
without sounding too much
like a live, laugh, love sign,
to give it my best shot.
I do believe that a good
ancestor is driven by hope.
When I began this program two years ago,
my aunt, a fellow public
health practitioner,
sent me an article called
"Hope, Cynicism, and the
Stories We Tell Ourselves."
The article astutely remarked,
"Critical thinking
without hope is cynicism.
Hope without critical
thinking is naivete."
This seemed, at the time, and even still,
the perfect description of
the public health conundrum:
the call to hope is
really a call to retain
a critical mind and a soft heart.
A critical mind to question everything:
the methods, the systems,
the dissemination strategies,
the funding mechanisms, the theories,
the power differentials,
the service delivery.
A soft heart to remember
why we do the work:
to see communities thrive,
to continue to believe
that change is possible,
to give the gifts that we were given
and the gifts we've cultivated
to create a world that people
actually want to live in.
Here in public health, hope
isn't really an option,
it is a necessity.
As practitioners of public health,
regardless of our concentration,
we witness, up close, the very worst
and the very best that
humanity has to offer.
This reminds me of a text
chain my roommates and I sent
after opening one of our
readings last spring:
"The Epidemiology of Human Suffering."
"Amazing," we said. "What
a warm and fuzzy field."
Many of us have seen patients turned away
because of lack of documentation,
have contended with
harmful policies passed
after decades of health advocacy,
have witnessed public trust dwindle
throughout the COVID-19 pandemic,
thwarting infection reduction plans.
Still, we continue to find hope
through many different avenues.
Hope comes in moments of curiosity,
in moments we feel
compelled to ask questions
about ourselves, others,
and the world around us.
Curiosity cultivates hope
through refusal of stagnation.
It insists there must be more:
new options, solutions, considerations.
I hope you hold on to the
power of asking, "But why?"
Hope comes in moments of love.
Before many of us knew each other,
we were just tiny boxes on Zoom screens,
smiling when our roommates or partners
or family members said
something from off-screen,
mouthing "thank you" to the
person who delivered us hot tea,
or laughing when our
pets entered our screen,
pausing our attention to text
our friends back mid-lecture,
and creating new relationships
through Zoom chat.
Love cultivates hope through remembering
that we are all whole
people with full lives.
I hope you continue to foster
love in your everyday life,
so you can continue to extend
love to the people you serve.
Hope comes in moments of creativity
when we utilize a
combination of imagination
and evidence-based practice
or a new strategy or a novel method.
Creativity cultivates hope
through the recognition
that public health and medical systems
that we live within
were created by someone.
Why wouldn't we create the next iteration?
I hope you acknowledge
your power as an individual
who will shape the future of health.
Finally and, in my unsolicited
opinion, most importantly,
hope comes in moments of humor.
Humor, I think, is
humanity's most endearing
survival tactic against adversity.
We laugh about irony.
We laugh hysterically when sleep-deprived,
something I'm sure none
of us can relate to.
We laugh, filled with adrenaline,
when we exhibit bravery
to speak truth to power.
We laugh to connect with
others, to release tension,
to try again and again and again.
I hope you find humor and
connection to keep you grounded.
Class of 2022, I don't
know exactly what it means
to be a good ancestor, but
I do know you are all it.
Your bright minds, your curiosity,
your ability to hold
the worst and the best
the world has to offer,
your wit and your humor,
your critical minds, and your soft hearts.
We're entering the field of public health
at a time in history when our
hope is so desperately needed.
And I do believe that
we have some despair.
I can't wait to see you out
there making your corner
of the world a better place to live in.
Congratulations.
(audience cheering)
- Nandini, thank you very
much for those words.
We're very grateful.
It's now my privilege to
introduce our distinguished
2022 Commencement
speaker, Dr. Heidi Larson.
She has to present to us
from the World Economic
Forum in Davos, Switzerland,
because she was previously
committed to that event.
Professor Heidi Larson
is the founding director
of the Vaccine Confidence Project
and is Professor of Anthropology,
Risk and Decision Science
at the London School of
Hygiene & Tropical Medicine.
She also holds a clinical professorship
at the University of Washington
and a guest professorship
at the University of Antwerp in Leuven.
Her research focuses on the analysis
of social and political factors
and managing risk and rumors,
including digitally-enabled disinformation
that can affect uptake
of health interventions.
Her current research
is particularly focused
on issues around public
cooperation during emergencies,
disease outbreak, natural disasters,
terrorism, and conflict.
Professor Larson previously headed
Global Immunization Communication
at UNICEF, chaired Gavi's,
that's the Global Alliance
for Vaccines and Immunization
advocacy taskforce,
and served on the World
Health Organization,
SAGE working group, on vaccine hesitancy.
She is author of a book called
"Stuck: How Vaccine Rumors Start
and Why They Don't Go Away,"
published in 2020 by
Oxford University Press.
She's published widely on the drivers
and enablers of vaccine confidence.
In 2021, she was awarded
the Edinburgh Medal,
in recognition of the role she has played
in recognizing importance of popular
and widespread
misunderstandings of vaccines.
BBC also named Professor Larson
as one of the hundred
most influential women
in the world in 2021.
Dr. Larson joins us via cyberspace
to give her 2022 Commencement address
to the MPH class of 2022.
Graduates, faculty, staff,
families, and friends,
it's a pleasure to introduce
my friend, Dr. Heidi Larson.
(audience applauding)
- Congratulations to all of you.
And I'm really sorry not to be with you
in-person in New Haven,
which I would've loved to do.
But I'm really grateful
for the opportunity
to prerecord this address.
And I chose to record it
in the science gallery
here in Bengaluru, India,
where I've been collaborating
in an exhibit on contagion,
and thought it was an appropriate setting
to be addressing you,
given their inspirational efforts
at making science more
engaging and accessible,
which is foundational to public health.
Well, what an important day this is.
It's a milestone in your
public health careers.
It's actually the beginning,
the commencement of your learning,
a different kind of learning,
a real-world learning,
and your leadership.
You are some of the top public health
emerging leaders in the world,
and we're all counting on you,
particularly after this
challenging couple years.
You couldn't have had
a more meaningful time
to earn your public health degree
than in the context of
this current pandemic.
You've also seen the real-world reality
of public health outside
of your classrooms,
the swirl of politics,
of publics, and science,
all competing, sometimes,
and not cooperating,
while trying to cooperate for attention.
Thankfully, not all public
health work is in crises,
and the best of public
health work helps to mitigate
and prevent extreme health outcomes
in the context of crisis and
other settings and emergencies.
As we slowly and
hopefully exit from COVID,
all eyes will be on building
preparedness and resilience
in the face of the next challenge,
whether it's a serious disease outbreak,
or other events such as natural disasters
with their health consequences.
We'll also need to address
the many health needs
that were overlooked or neglected
because we had all eyes on COVID
in these past couple years.
Some of these issues,
like even mental health,
which were exacerbated,
made worse during COVID.
I read a recent report
that the pandemic led
to an additional 53 million cases
of depression in the world since COVID.
We have a lot of work to do.
As you choose your path after graduation,
because public health embraces
so many different paths
and the wonder of public health,
and what I've loved being
an anthropologist working
in public health is the diversity
of people I've worked with:
my research group, the
Vaccine Confidence Project.
We have computer scientists,
mathematical modelers,
psychiatrists, political scientists,
epidemiologists, vaccinologists.
And it's the wonder of bringing
these disciplines together
to ensure more robust public health.
The biggest message I can
give you when I thought about,
"What can I tell such a
brilliant group of graduates
after everything they've already learned?"
and one of the key messages
I thought was be open, listen carefully.
This is the beginning of learning.
Everyone around you as you enter
into your chosen role/setting
that you work in,
you'll be around people who, each of them,
has had a different experience
these last few years.
Different challenges at many levels.
Building the trust of those you work with
in your new setting will be
crucial to building trust,
listening in even small ways
to what they've been through
as a gesture of caring about the others.
Public trust has been
a key issue, a lever,
a key lever of public cooperation
around the multiple restrictions
and challenges we've had during COVID,
imposed on people for "the greater good."
Well, what we, as public health community,
feel is the greater good
wasn't necessarily felt
to be the greater good locally
or for some populations.
This has been a challenge and
a relationship-building time.
Countries where there was higher trust
in government fared must better than those
who didn't have as much
trust in government.
We learned, for instance,
that our global vaccine
confidence research
that the biggest predictor
of COVID vaccine willingness
was actually the perception
that government was
handling the pandemic well.
The more confidence in the government
and how they were handling the pandemic,
the more willingness to accept a vaccine
that was administered, regulated,
and, sometimes, required by government.
I care passionately about public trust.
And I'm hugely concerned about the recent
World Economic Forum risk report
which rated social risk cohesion erosion,
the ability of society to cooperate,
as the global risk that worsened
the most dramatically during
COVID, during the pandemic.
We would have thought, we
could have thought and hoped,
that this would have
been a time to embellish
and strengthen social cohesion,
but, for whatever reason,
some of which were very
different in different settings,
social cohesion and cooperation
didn't fare as well,
but they're foundational to public health.
And this will be absolutely
crucial for you to consider
and think about how you can contribute
to rebuilding it in your work ahead.
My second message, besides
be open, listen carefully,
is be ready for surprises.
One of the biggest learnings
of the pandemic has been
the importance of being responsive
to changing circumstances, uncertainty,
even changing science, evolving science.
That's been one of the biggest
challenges of the pandemic,
keeping the public on board
while the information was changing,
weighing what was the
best available evidence
to make the best decisions,
recognizing that they may change.
This is not the stuff of textbooks,
of linear thinking about
evidence to policy.
Multiple types of evidence
and situational awareness
weigh into public health decisions.
Knowing that, again, they may need
to change as situations evolve.
The world did not stand
together in a kumbaya moment
to get us through this crisis.
The best successes when people ask me,
"Where did you see successes?"
the successes I saw were hyper local.
They were local communities.
They were giving and caring
and mutual trust settings
that people pulled together
and understood each other's needs.
And, also, the local health
institutions, local governments,
local schools understood
their local community.
Local and locality mattered,
because, sometimes, national leaders,
global leaders that we would have expected
to line up together, weren't doing that,
as many pandemic preparedness reports
and commissions had anticipated,
assumed, or at least hoped.
Some leaders, as you know, misled publics
away from the science, down
the rabbit hole of conspiracy.
In those settings, when you can't have
that kind of confidence
in a national leader,
localness and local leadership, mayors,
and others in local settings
matter tremendously,
religious leaders, others,
who the public trust
when there is so much uncertainty.
What has been particularly striking
and concerning about the nature
and scope of conspiracy,
rumors, and misinformation,
a topic I've spent a
tremendous amount of time
with my research group on
these past couple years,
is the level of aggression
and anger behind it.
There's been tremendous
emotion during this pandemic.
And, somehow, moving forward,
we're going to need to calm
and rebuild a more hopeful, optimistic,
rather than angry and anxious public.
It's not gonna be easy,
but I think we're all
counting on all of you
and your colleagues in other universities
to work towards this,
to be good listeners and trust-builders,
because we have a pretty
fractured environment,
but not everywhere.
We need to build on the hope,
build on the optimism,
build on the local trust.
In the beginning of the pandemic,
which was an early signal that
we had some challenges ahead,
I remember nearly 60 5G
towers were set on fire.
Others vandalized, people
working there were harassed,
and I was really startled
at how extreme their reactions were.
And some of it was against people
not wanting to be told what to do,
how to run their life and where.
As vaccines became available
and increasingly required in
many settings, as you know,
they, too, have been a
trigger of anger and anxiety
for some populations, for some people.
Some of it was more anxiety
than anger. It's uncertain.
It was so new. It was so quick.
And it amplified.
There was already underlying trends
of vaccine hesitancy around the world.
But where we did well, it was
a signal of trust-building.
I've always been struck.
I never expected to be spending
nearly 20 years of my
life working in the field
of vaccine confidence after
many years working in AIDS,
which was very much more bottom-up
than top-down as a pandemic response.
Vaccine confidence has such a window
on people's ability to cooperate.
The last message, which
I've already suggested
and referred to, is to never
forget the emotions of publics.
And they're more heightened than ever.
Publics are hugely heterogeneous.
There's no one public.
And in that sense, no one public health.
They're hugely heterogeneous,
with multiple histories,
beliefs, political stances, and emotions,
and all of these factors have
influenced their willingness,
or not, to cooperate for the greater good.
All of these factors
matter as we work together
for public health and better health.
Your effectiveness as
public health practitioners
will be determined by your alertness
and sensitivity to these human factors.
We have to embrace these factors
without losing the foundational
science behind them.
While we can think of universal principles
for public health, and
perhaps shared goals,
there will be varied
journeys to get there.
There is no one universal best practice.
There are many local best practices.
Be open, listen carefully.
Be open, listen carefully
as you start your journey
and don't, don't stop listening.
It's the most important
thing that I can think of.
Each time you listen, it
is a gesture of caring
about what the other
person or people think.
It's a trust builder. Thank you.
And, again, congratulations.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Professor Larson.
If you didn't detect a British accent,
it's because Professor
Larson is from Connecticut.
We would like to now
acknowledge our student awards
for this year's commencement.
We ask that all student award
recipients come to the stage
to receive their award
when their name is called.
We will be foregoing our
handshakes in deference to COVID,
but we're allowed elbow
bumps and whatever.
So the first award is the Dean's Prize
for Outstanding MPH Thesis
and also the Wilbur G. Downs
Outstanding Thesis Prize
in International Health.
The faculty and I commend all of you
for the excellence of your
theses and capstone projects.
It's my great pleasure to acknowledge
the 2022 recipients of these two prizes,
the Dean's Prize and
the Wilbur Downs Prize.
The recipient of the Dean's Prize
for Outstanding MPH Thesis is...
Are you ready?
Nandini Deo.
(audience cheering)
(Sten chuckles)
Nandini receives this
award for her thesis,
"She trusts us to love her, you know?
Using a Love Ethic framework
to explore faith navigation
and acceptance processes
among Mormon mothers
of LGBTQ+ individuals."
The purpose of this study
was to better understand
faith navigation and
LGBTQ acceptance processes
among mothers in the
Church of Jesus Christ
of Latter-day Saints,
in order to better inform
public health engagement
with highly religious parents
of sexual and gender minority children.
Nandini, please come
to receive your award.
(audience cheering)
- [Nandini] Thank you!
- The recipient of the Wilbur G. Downs
Outstanding Thesis Prize
in International Health
is Georgiana Esteves.
(audience cheering)
Georgiana...
(Sten laughs)
Could be a long afternoon. Just kidding.
Georgiana receives this
award for her thesis,
"Support or Interference:
Relational Influences
on Mothers' Exclusive
Breastfeeding Practices in Ghana."
Childhood malnutrition is a challenge
that needs to be understood
as a global health threat.
Exclusive breastfeeding is
recognized as the best practice
to improve a child's growth
and cognitive development
in the first months of life.
The World Health Organization recommends
exclusive breastfeeding until six months.
Mothers need family support
to adhere to exclusive
breastfeeding practice.
This study aimed to understand
the interpersonal level
relational influences
of fathers, grandmothers,
and other family members
on the mother-child dyad adherence
to exclusive breastfeeding practices,
as well as document community
and societal influences
on exclusive breastfeeding.
Georgiana, please come
to receive your award.
(audience cheering)
The Henry J. Chauncey
Jr. Inspiration Award.
And Mr. Chauncey goes
by his nickname, Sam.
So the Sam Chauncey Inspiration
Award was established
in recognition of Mr. Sam Chauncey,
who developed our program
in Health Management
and fostered its close collaboration
with the Yale School of Management.
A former secretary of the university
and distinguished member of the Yale
and New Haven communities,
Sam has been both an agent of change
and dear friend of YSPH.
This award was initiated
by the Health Management
program class of 1999
and is now supported by the school.
It is given to the graduating
Health Management student
who most exemplifies
innovation, integrity,
leadership, and community service.
This year's recipient
of the Chauncey Award is Victoria Clarke.
(audience cheering)
Who was also our flag-bearer today.
Vicki came to YSPH in 2020
with a Bachelor of Arts and
Science, Technology & Society,
with a Correlate Sequence in
Biology from Vassar College,
whose president came from YSPH.
Vicki deserves recognition
not only for her scholarly
achievements at Yale,
but her impressive
commitment to leadership
within the university and beyond.
She has served as vice president
of the Student Association
of the YSPH board
as well as a Health Care
Management student leader
and peer mentor.
She's served as a Student Fellow
in the Solomon Center
for Health Law and Policy
in the Yale Law School,
has served as a research assistant
in the Connecticut Emerging
Infections Program at YSPH
on a COVID-19 vaccine breakthrough study,
and has aided multiple COVID-19
pandemic-related projects
at the school and at the state level.
Vicki's ability to lead on
multiple fronts with compassion,
kindness, and strength
has inspired her peers,
as well as the faculty and staff at YSPH.
It would not be an exaggeration
to say that Vicki has become
a part of the very fabric of YSPH
in her short, but impactful, time with us.
Vicki, please come to receive your award.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
The Lowell Levin Award for Excellence
in Global Health is awarded
to a graduating student
whose work addresses health
promotion and global health.
The recipient is selected based on
their internship experience
and overall academic record,
as well as their academic leadership
and community engagement.
Professor Levin was a dear friend to many,
a YSPH alumnus on our faculty,
the first head of the YSPH
International Health Division.
I'm very pleased to announce
that the Lowell Levin Award for Excellence
in Global Health has been awarded to...
Are your ready again? Georgiana Esteves.
(audience cheering)
I'll try that pronunciation
again. Georgiana Esteves.
Georgiana came to YSPH after
working with the Dara Institute
in Rio de Janeiro, Brazil, for five years.
The Dara Institute is a
civil society organization
that works to promote
health and human development
by implementing and fostering
an integrated approach to fight poverty.
She's also a registered
nutritionist in Brazil
and managed her private practice
for seven years until
joining YSPH in 2020.
Since her arrival, she's
been a very engaged student
in the Department of Social
and Behavioral Sciences,
pursuing the Global Health Concentration
as well as the Maternal and
Child Health Promotion Track.
Through her passion for global health
and by leveraging her past experiences,
she helped to facilitate
a Global Health signature internship
with the Dara Institute.
As a result, a current
Global Health student
will be working there this summer.
Georgiana's academic performance
in global health has been exceptional.
Her thesis project is based on
a highly innovative qualitative
analysis documenting
the role that fathers can play
in supporting infant feeding
and other caregiving practices
in Ghana, West Africa.
Her influential work
is now informing UNICEF
and other agencies on how to better design
and implement effective infant feeding
and maternal-child
health programs involving
both adult and teenage fathers.
Georgiana, please come
to receive your award.
(audience cheering)
Our annual YSPH Student Award
for Outstanding Contributions
in Diversity, Equity, and
Inclusion, DEI for short,
recognizes one or more
graduating MPH students
who have demonstrated a
significant contribution
towards creating and fostering
a diverse and inclusive
community while at YSPH.
I'm pleased to announce a
three-way tie for this award
to Lauren Nicole Cueto,
Aivy Duong,
and Simileoluwa Elizabeth Falako.
Let me try-
(audience cheering)
Simileoluwa Elizabeth Falako.
(Sten chuckles)
These three award
recipients were recognized
for creating community
and implementing programs
to help bring students together.
They did significant work
in organizing efforts
to increase a sense of inclusion
and belonging for students at YSPH
through a range of activities,
such as supporting recruitment efforts
and organizing student events.
And this wasn't as easy
year to be doing this,
with all the COVID constraints.
Students said, quote, "They
have created such a welcoming
and inclusive environment
by producing group events
that spoke to various groups of students
and being valuable resources
on campus for all students."
Simileoluwa, Lauren, and Aivy,
please come to receive your award.
(audience cheering)
Okay, here we go.
There's one, there's
two, and there's three.
Now, could we all gather around here?
Let's take a photograph.
(audience cheering)
Congratulations.
We're now going to present
the faculty and fellow Teaching Awards,
acknowledge our Teaching Awards
for this year's commencement.
We ask that all Teaching Award
recipients come to the stage
to receive their award
when their name is called.
The YSPH Teaching Fellow
Award recognizes a student
who demonstrates outstanding performance
as a Teaching Fellow, TF as we call it,
and promise as a future teacher.
The recipient of the 2022
Teaching Fellow Award is Thomas Shao-
(audience cheering)
(audience member shouting)
(Sten laughs)
Tom is a second year MPH student
in the Department of
Environmental Health Sciences.
His nominator, Mike Wininger, says,
"Tom is a relentless bridge-builder.
From study parties to friend meet-ups
to mentorship match-ups,
Tom organized countless opportunities
for friends to be made and
partnerships to be created.
And when Tom's semester-end
student reviews were analyzed
through a sentiment analysis algorithm,
Tom's score was the highest
score ever achieved by a-
(audience cheering)
(audience member shouting)
(Sten laughs)
Highest score ever achieved
by a Biostats teaching team member,
and nearly double that of
the course instructor."
(audience laughing)
When prompted for criticisms
of Tom's teaching,
the students had two suggestions for Tom:
pick a different hour
to host your section,
and number two, don't tap the microphone
to test the room mic.
Those were the two
suggestions that he got.
Those were the only two.
Tom was beloved, as you can tell,
and these critiques are
as harsh as it gets.
Students underscored that
"he's patient, understanding,
and determined to ensure
that students leave
his section feeling confident
about what they have
just learned in EPH 505."
Students also expressed
that "Tom is so awesome,
so approachable, so
knowledgeable, and flexible."
People say that about me, don't they?
No, no, no.
(audience laughing)
No, I guess, in fact, they don't.
"He was super helpful,
especially during lab,
when many of us are learning
to code for the first time,
and I really appreciated that he sent kind
and supportive notes to us
throughout the semester."
Tom, finally, please come
to receive your award.
(audience cheering)
All right. We now turn to the faculty.
The YSPH Distinguished Student
Mentoring Award recognizes
a faculty member as a leader
in shaping the next generation
of public health professionals
and one who serves as a role model,
conveys passion for public health,
has clear and high expectations,
encourages students to
achieve their full potential,
is sensitive to student
needs and concerns,
and makes extraordinary
efforts to help their students.
Candidates for this award are nominated
by graduating students and
are selected by a committee
of both students and faculty.
This year, the 2022 recipient
of the Distinguished Student Mentor Award
is Dr. Ijeoma Opara.
(audience cheering)
(audience member shouting)
Dr. Opara, who's been here about a year,
is an assistant professor
in the Department of Social
& Behavioral Sciences
at our School of Public Health.
She is the founder and director
of the Substance Abuse
& Sexual Health Lab,
www.oparalab.org.
Her research interests
focus on HIV/AIDS, STIs,
and substance use
prevention for urban youth,
including racial and gender-specific
prevention interventions for Black girls,
and community-based participatory
research with urban youth.
Dr. Opara was praised by students
for being an inspiration.
They wrote, "In order to
be an inspiring mentor,
a professor must possess
the following qualities:
ability to provoke original ideas,
dedication to their work and
their students, compassion,
and ability to instill
passion in their students.
Dr. Opara exemplifies
all of these qualities."
Students also wrote,
"Dr. Opara is the epitome
of the positive impact
exceptional mentors can have
on minority students
at elite institutions."
Ijeoma, my friend, please
come to receive your award.
(audience cheering)
(Sten faintly speaking)
The Distinguished Teaching Award,
also called Teacher of the Year,
is the school's highest
honor for its faculty,
bestowed by its graduating students.
Quality teaching is one of
the most important influences
on a student's experience at Yale,
and this award recognizes
the recipient's leading role
in shaping the next generation
of public health professionals.
The 2022 recipient of the
Distinguished Teaching Award
is Professor David Paltiel,
in the Department of Health
Policy and Management.
(audience cheering)
(Sten laughs)
The objective that guides Dr. Paltiel's
scholarly activities is to
promote a reasoned approach
to decision-making and resource allocation
in public health and medicine.
Trained in the field
of operations research,
Dr. Paltiel designs and
implements policy models
and cost-effectiveness analyses.
He has a special interest
and expertise in HIV/AIDS
and has published broadly
on the cost-effectiveness
of testing, prevention,
treatment, and care,
both in the United States
and around the world.
David is praised by his students
for being excited by, quote,
"every student question,
answering them with eagerness
and appreciation for students' curiosity
and creative, critical thinking.
He created a sense of community
among his students and TFs
by celebrating our growth
and recognizing the specific
contributions people made
to the group's learning."
I am so fortunate to have known
and been influenced by Dr. Paltiel
for all of over a quarter century.
David, please come forward
and receive your award.
(audience cheering)
I forgot to mention David's
important work in COVID-19.
He pivoted his experience immediately
and made nationally influential
contributions in the area,
but this is all for teaching.
This is not for that.
So, Tom, Ijeoma, and David
will have their names inscribed
on the Awards Wall on the
first floor teaching area
in 60 College Street.
(audience applauding)
Next, we would like to acknowledge
our new faculty Research Awards.
Just initiated in recent years
by our associate dean, Melinda Irwin.
Our new faculty Research Awards recognize
distinguished peer-reviewed manuscripts.
The research awardees were
already highlighted in detail
at our YSPH faculty
meeting earlier this month
to highlight the public health impact
of their impressive research.
However, I'd like to share
the awards with you briefly.
The Early Career Investigator
Research Award is given
to a YSPH faculty appointment
assistant professor
or associate research scientist,
who is either the first or last author
on a given published manuscript.
And we had a tie for this award.
Congratulations to Dr. Kai
Chen for his paper entitled
"Role of meteorological
factors in the transmission
of SARS-CoV-2 in the United States."
He published this in
"Nature Communications,"
and to Dr. Fan Li in
Department of Biostatistics
for his paper titled
"Sample size considerations
for stepped wedge designs
with subclusters,"
published in "Biometrics."
Next is the Investigator Research Award,
which is presented to a
YSPH primary faculty member
of any track or rank who
was first or last author
on the published manuscript.
Congratulations to Professor
Becca Levy on the paper,
"Impact of Media-Based Negative
and Positive Age Stereotypes
on Older Individuals' Mental Health,"
published in "The Journals
of Gerontology: Series B."
And to Dr. Michaela Dinan on her paper
"Analysis of Sociodemographic, Clinical,
and Genomic Factors Associated
with Breast Cancer Mortality
in the Linked Surveillance, Epidemiology,
and End Results and Medicare Database,"
published in "JAMA Network Open."
Our next award is the YSPH
COVID-19 Research Award,
granted to a YSPH faculty
member or group of YSPH faculty
whose original research published
in 2021 focused on COVID-19.
Congratulations to...
Are you ready?
David Paltiel and Jason
Schwartz, on their paper,
"Assessing COVID-19 Prevention Strategies
to Permit the Safe Opening
of Residential Colleges in Fall 2021,"
published in "Annals of Internal Medicine"
and recognized as one of
the highest impact papers
in that journal that year,
and Dr. Chantal Vogels,
Professor Albert Ko,
Professor Saad Omer,
and Dr. Nate Grubaugh,
on their paper the "Impact of circulating
SARS-CoV-2 variants on mRNA
vaccine-induced immunity,"
published in "Nature."
Our next award is the YSPH
Health Equity Research Award,
granted to a YSPH primary faculty member's
exceptional health equity-related
original research published in 2021.
Congratulations to Dr.
Yusuf Ransome on his paper,
"Neighborhood Social Cohesion
and Inequalities in
COVID-19 Diagnosis Rates
by Area-Level Black/African
American Racial Composition,"
published in the "Journal
of Urban Health,"
and Dr. Terika McCall on her paper,
"Development of a Mobile App
to Support Self-management
of Anxiety and Depression
in African American
Women: Usability Study,"
published in "JMIR Formative Research."
The Team Research Award is
our final research prize,
granted to a YSPH team,
two or more primary faculty members,
with one faculty member either
being first or last author.
Congratulations to Hannah
Ehrlich, Amy Bei, Dan Weinberger,
Josh Warren, and Sunhil
Parikh on their paper entitled
"Mapping partner drug resistance
to guide antimalarial
combination therapy policies
in sub-Saharan Africa,"
published in the "Proceedings
of National Academies of Sciences,"
and Tyler Shelby, Xin
Zhou, Donna Spiegelman,
Lauretta Grau, Linda
Niccolai, and Luke Davis
on their paper entitled
"Lessons Learned From
COVID-19 Contact Tracing
During a Public Health Emergency:
A Prospective Implementation Study,"
published in "Frontiers in Public Health."
Let's have a round of applause
for all of these
outstanding investigators.
(audience applauding)
Now is the moment you've
all been waiting for.
We take time to honor
all of our MPH graduates.
Can our graduates please follow
the direction of staff
to proceed to the stage?
When your name is called,
please cross in front of the podium
to receive your diploma from me.
We will forego handshakes given continued
SARS-CoV-2 viral transmission.
The Yale School of Public
Health Alumni Association
will be giving you your pin
and welcoming you the AYAPH,
the Association of Yale
Alumni in Public Health,
of which you are now members.
And it is my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Mayur Desai,
director of the Advanced
Professional Program,
who will introduce the candidates
for the Master of Public
Health degree in that program.
(audience cheering)
- [Mayur] Ehsan Khaled Abualanain.
I'll go ahead and read the names of those
who aren't here as well.
Friedrich Leopold Ackermann.
(audience applauding)
Abinet Mathias Aklilu.
Richa Attre.
(audience cheering)
Amit Bardia.
Lawrence James Castillo.
(audience cheering)
Li Ling Chen.
(audience applauding)
Dante Costa.
(audience cheering)
Cara Rozlyn Costanzo.
Kingsley Cruickshank.
(audience cheering)
John-Paul Singh Deol.
Alison Langford Durran.
(audience cheering)
Oluwatomini Ayomide Fashina.
Tod Gulick.
Dan Patrick Kelleher.
(audience cheering)
Frank Masige Willy Kussaga.
Jaewon Lee.
(audience cheering)
Kristopher Lawrence McLucas.
Gayathri Theresa Narendran.
(audience cheering)
Barbara Awuor Odac.
Rujvee Pareshkumar Patel.
(audience cheering)
Ashok Krishna Perumal.
(audience applauding)
Matthew Dylan Pichert.
Rock Cjay Positano.
(audience applauding)
Richard Robert Rodriguez.
(audience cheering)
Ahmad Raafat Saleh.
Zia Shakir.
(audience cheering)
Girija Shetkar.
Richard Smith.
(audience applauding)
Wanyi Tang.
Jean Verheyden.
Hui Emily Yang.
(audience cheering)
Kexuan Zhang.
(audience applauding)
It is now my pleasure to
introduce Professor Shuangge Ma,
chair of the Department of Biostatistics,
who will introduce candidates
for the Master of Public
Health degree in that program.
(audience applauding)
- [Shuangge] It's my great
honor to introduce candidates
for MPH in Biostatistics.
Dieyi Chen.
(audience applauding)
Yanjun Chen.
Yingtong Chen.
(audience applauding)
Zhuo Chen.
(audience cheering)
Yi Dai.
(audience applauding)
Hanfeng Huang.
Yi Jiang.
(audience applauding)
Chaihyun Kim.
Xiaofan Liu.
(audience applauding)
Enhao Ma.
Yulu Pan.
(audience cheering)
Megan Pinaire.
Ruiling Tu.
(audience applauding)
Yiting Wang.
Meilin Zhan.
(audience applauding)
Now, it's my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Judith Lichtman,
chair of the Department of
Chronic Disease Epidemiology,
to introduce candidates
for MPH in that department.
Thanks.
(audience applauding)
- [Judith] It's a pleasure to be able
to announce our candidates.
Mahna Alyami.
(audience applauding)
Nicole-Anne Ancheta Ballesteros.
(audience cheering)
Paola Bojorquez-Ramirez.
Lauren Nicole Cueto.
(audience cheering)
Hollie Nicole Dowd.
Natalie Sophie Henning.
(audience cheering)
Katherine Luis Ho.
Dana Norbert Joseph.
(audience cheering)
Esther Joo Won Kang.
Erika-Ann Fumiko Kim.
(audience cheering)
Danielle Marie Kline.
Hang Li.
(audience applauding)
Meghan Elizabeth Lindsay.
(audience cheering)
- Oh, one more, on more, one more.
(Judith chuckles)
(audience laughing)
- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- [Judith] Marie-Claire Meadows.
Carlos Mauricio Mejia Arbelaez.
(audience cheering)
Chinenye Maryanne Okafor.
Connor Jesse Peck.
(audience cheering)
Shamar Samuel Smalls.
Jasmine I-Shin Su.
(audience cheering)
Vani Topkar.
Mei Wang.
(audience cheering)
Ruiyan Michelle Wang.
Joseph Williams.
(audience cheering)
Clara Ming Hei Wong.
(audience applauding)
I'm just reading one
last name. Yunfan Zhang.
(audience applauding)
It is now my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Vasilis Vasiliou,
chair of the Department of
Environmental Health Sciences,
who will introduce the candidates
for the Master of Public
Health degree in that program.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- [Vasilis] Hello, I'm honored
to introduce our MPH candidates.
Giselle Rita Maria Bellia.
(audience cheering)
Jiaqi Cui.
(audience applauding)
Liora Nina Fiksel.
(audience cheering)
Emily Elizabeth Johnson.
Brady Keith Rowe.
(audience cheering)
Once again, let's call Tom Shao.
Phoenix Rongcan Sun.
(audience cheering)
And Yakun Zhou.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
It's now my pleasure to
call Dr. Linda Niccolai,
interim chair of the
Department of Epidemiology
and microbial Diseases,
who will introduce the candidates
for the Master's of Public
Health degree in that program.
(audience applauding)
- [Linda] So it is my great pleasure
to introduce the following candidates.
Elliana Sophia Barbell.
(audience cheering)
Ann Victoria Lokelani Basting.
Aishwarya Bhattacharya.
(audience cheering)
Eli Franklin Bierman.
Kendall Billig.
(audience cheering)
Lily V. Carruthers.
Allison Catalano.
(audience cheering)
Baqar Husain.
Robert Tobias Toby Koch.
(audience cheering)
Hannah Lemanske.
Yueqi Li.
(audience cheering)
Zitong Lin.
Yicong Liu.
(audience cheering)
Rachel Amanda Lobe-Costonis.
Caroline M. McWilliams.
(audience cheering)
Sarah Yukari Michels.
Guinevere Vanbuskirk Oliver.
(audience cheering)
William Thomas Pelletiers.
Hanna Peterson.
(audience cheering)
Thomas Arthur Grant Quijano.
Alexander James Robertson.
(audience cheering)
Hannah Jane Sproch.
Mengting Su.
(audience cheering)
Mary Martinovna Tate.
Alice Zhao.
(audience cheering)
It's now my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Howard Forman,
director of the Health
Care Management program,
who will introduce the candidates
for Master's of Public Health
degree in that program.
(audience applauding)
- [Howard] It's my really distinct honor
to introduce the candidates
for the Master's of Public Health degree
in the Health Care Management program.
Oh, hold on.
We're back. We're back, yeah.
I'm the only one who didn't print
my own thing, but, you know...
Rahma Ahmed.
(audience cheering)
Saron Araya.
Daisy Bourne.
(audience cheering)
Victoria Ashley Clarke.
(audience applauding)
Eesha Dave.
(audience cheering)
Michelle Deloison-Baum.
(audience applauding)
Patrick Dempsey.
(audience cheering)
Mila Dorji.
Yuxuan Du.
(audience cheering)
Aivy Duong.
Benjamin Paul Engler.
(audience cheering)
Sarah Gannon.
(audience applauding)
Derek Kenneth Goshay.
(audience cheering)
Tyler John Kellenberger.
Jingwen Li.
(audience cheering)
Lydia Jinmo Li.
Meiyi Li.
(audience applauding)
Xiuyan Li.
Xun Lu.
(audience applauding)
Sijia Ma.
(audience cheering)
Tyler Miao.
Hilary Judith Moss.
(audience applauding)
Phyllis Nokuthaba Panashe Mugadza.
(audience cheering)
Benjamin Thomas Rosen.
(audience applauding)
Qinnan Shen.
Ritesh Kumar Singh.
(audience cheering)
Kevin Soun.
Melanie Suzanne Taub.
(audience applauding)
Shuo Wang.
Wei Zhang.
(audience applauding)
Xiaohan Zhou.
(audience cheering)
It is now my pleasure to
introduce Dr. David Paltiel,
professor in the Department
of Health Policy,
who will introduce the candidates
for Master of Public Health degree.
(audience applauding)
- [David] For the Master of
Public Health in Health Policy.
Christian Abraham.
(audience cheering)
Priscilla Badu-Sekyere.
Nicole Brussel Faria.
(audience cheering)
Shannon Carter.
Jacob Chen!
(audience cheering)
Rebecca Gillman!
(David chuckles)
(audience applauding)
Julian Johnson.
(audience cheering)
Sreeja Kondeti.
Guiyu Li.
(audience applauding)
Elaine Louden.
(audience cheering)
Laura Makin.
Megan Malloy.
(audience cheering)
Anna Marguerite Rabil.
Miranda Rector.
(audience cheering)
Ian Reilly.
Oh, oh.
When you already have one Yale degree,
why do you need another, right?
Where was I?
Leah Robinson!
(audience cheering)
(David chuckles)
Good job, Ian.
Madeline Josephine Sale.
(audience cheering)
Meg Stellini.
Elyse Vanderwoude.
(audience applauding)
And Isabel Skye Wanner.
It is now my pleasure to
call Dr. Trace Kershaw,
chair of the Department of
Social and Behavioral Sciences,
who will introduce the candidates
for the Master of Public
Health degree in that program.
(Sten laughs)
(audience cheering)
- [Trace] All right, SBS,
let's take this home.
(audience cheering)
Here we go.
Natalia Castellanos Gonzalez.
(audience cheering)
Maya Frances Tracey Dennis.
Nandini Milind Deo.
(audience cheering)
Betty Duran-Becerra.
Georgiana Esteves.
(audience cheering)
Simileoluwa Elizabeth Falako.
Qiao Fan.
(audience applauding)
Paige Farrenkopf.
(audience cheering)
Hannah Carolyn Gorman.
Audrey Yingan Huang.
(audience cheering)
Emily Zhen Ning Hwang.
Margaret Cavendish Kellogg.
(audience cheering)
Caroline Alexandra Magee.
Risika Mohanty.
(audience cheering)
Christine Pham.
Senyte Pierce.
(audience cheering)
Jasmine Teresa Rios.
Janet Arena Rojina.
(audience cheering)
Mariko Fujimoto Rooks.
Bailee Freida Jean Rue.
(audience cheering)
Kalla Maxine Pascual Sy.
Kendall Naomi Watanabe.
(audience cheering)
Julia Michelle Winschel.
- Class of 2022, please stand.
All of you. Congratulations to you all.
(audience cheering)
You may be seated.
Thanks also to our program directors,
representative of AYAPH,
our chairs, our associate deans,
and especially Frank Grosso
and his extraordinary team,
not only for this ceremony,
but for our lunch.
We're very grateful.
I would now like to take
a moment to acknowledge
our friends who aren't here,
the YSPH students receiving their PhD
and Master of Science degrees
from the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences.
But they're really ours, don't you think?
The 21 Doctoral graduates
and 33 MS graduates are
listed in your program.
And they're recognized more fully
through Yale's Graduate
School Commencement events,
which is where they are now.
Please join me in recognizing all of them
with a round of applause.
(audience cheering)
I immediately see that the dean's
closing remarks are a little too long,
but don't worry, we'll be there.
We're seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel
of this extraordinary day.
As we approach the end of our ceremony,
I address you, the YSPH Class of 2022.
The degrees you've been
awarded today are a testament
to your commitment to promoting
wellness in communities,
promoting health equity, and
alleviating human suffering
through the field of public health.
The faculty and I salute
you for your perseverance,
especially through the travails
of the COVID-19 pandemic.
We also wish to thank, again,
all the families and
friends of the graduates
for joining us in this celebration.
All of you in attendance,
families, faculty, and staff alike,
have encouraged and inspired
our students to succeed
in this exciting stage
of their career studies.
Yale University also wants to acknowledge
that Indigenous Peoples
and Nations have stewarded
through generations
the lands and waterways
of what is now the state of Connecticut.
We honor and respect the
enduring relationship
that exists between these Peoples
and Nations and this land.
Graduates, you're moving
on to your job searches,
your new jobs, or your continuing doctoral
or professional studies
at a time of true crisis in
our nation and the world.
Rather than facts, some would promote lies
and so-called alternative facts.
Rather than policy built
on an evidence base,
some would promote partisan fictions
for their own short-term gain.
Rather than strengthening
fairness and democracy,
some would roll back the
clock to restrict voting
and biasing electoral processes.
"America First" was the motto of Americans
who were pro-Nazi in the 1930s.
"America First" is now the motto
for pro-authoritarian, pro-aggression,
and racist and anti-immigrant
philosophies in the 2020s.
What, then, are scientists to
do to help guide policymakers
and sincerely motivated political leaders?
I suggest three strategies.
First, make every effort to take
your peer-focused research publications
and your professional presentations
into a community context.
This is easier than ever
with strong social media
and online publication options.
In this way, you will democratize science,
bringing lay descriptions
of your work to persons
who will never read it
in "Nature," "JAMA,"
or the "American Journal
of Public Health."
Second, seek to engage your local online
or print newspapers with editorials,
with commentaries to
counteract misinformation
that is promulgated by
anti-science forces.
Third, try your very best
to clarify scientific
and social misinformation
in your family and friendship groups,
your local parent-teachers
associations and governments,
and your fraternal organizations
and places of worship.
Listen to alternative points of view,
and seek to find common ground,
but then address misinformation.
Trust me, with your public
health degree in hand,
your legitimacy will be enhanced
and you can change hearts and minds.
I would be remiss in not acknowledging
the acute suffering of
our fellow human beings
in such settings as Rohingya
or Syrian refugee camps,
in Afghanistan and Yemen, in
the Tigray region of Ethiopia,
and, most notably, in Ukraine.
Less obvious at present is the growing
climate change migration
of persons displaced
by desertification, deforestation,
water and food shortages,
and disturbed fisheries and agriculture.
Also less obvious is the continuing crisis
of suboptimal nutrition
and sedentary lifestyles,
obstacles to healthy aging,
inequities in access to health care,
ongoing harmful substance use,
links of suboptimal housing and health,
systematic socioeconomic
disadvantages, infectious threats,
and toxic environmental exposures.
We can influence all these challenges,
but we must make our science accessible.
YSPH has made major
strides towards improving
our communications to the
public and our policymakers.
We intend to do much more.
I invite you to stay in touch
with us and partner with us
and the broader Yale community,
including our alumni.
And we want to advocate towards
broad welfare of humanity,
particularly those most vulnerable
due to systematic economic
and housing discrimination
that might lead to food deserts,
risk of injury and violence,
educational disadvantages,
and so many other
health-linked social issues.
The good news is that in our profession,
we spend our professional lives
working towards mitigation
of these legacies of
structural disadvantage,
health inequity, racial discrimination,
and extreme economic disparities.
We strive for improved health
systems and functioning.
We seek cleaner environments
and addressing the greenhouse
gas emissions crisis.
We identify and mitigate the
social determinants of disease.
We seek to motivate and
facilitate healthful behaviors.
The personal and community antecedents
of rising chronic diseases
and ongoing infectious disease
threats are characterized
and then interventions are
designed and promulgated.
Importantly, the methods of public health
in such disciplines as biostatistics,
data sciences, health informatics,
and implementation sciences are the source
of discovery and innovation.
Our global partnerships enable discovery
and capacity-building in low
and middle-income countries
and our students are in the
center of so much of this work.
We are privileged to be in
the field of public health
and your faculty are pleased to honor you
on this day of your achievements.
Finally, thank you most sincerely
to our Student Affairs team
that I mentioned a moment ago.
They've worked so hard.
Dean Grosso, Registrar Stacey Tuttle,
alongside my own colleagues
in the Office of the Dean.
They've supported you
for the past few years,
starting during the application process
and throughout your
graduate experience at Yale.
Please join me in thanking them
for everything they've done
throughout your graduate training
at the Yale School of Public Health.
(audience applauding)
Please stay in touch with your
old teachers and the AYAPH,
our Association for Yale
Alumni in Public Health,
in which you are now subscribed.
Let us know about the work
you do, your successes,
and your willingness to
advise current students,
mentor them, to receive
future summer interns,
in the positions you
now find yourselves in,
and to contribute to
the Annual Alumni Fund
for their scholarships in the future.
We will always value your
advice and your support.
And a personal thank you to
students, staff, and faculty
for their support of my
five-year tenure as your dean.
This concludes the YSPH Diploma Ceremony.
We ask that guests remain in their seats
until the representing
faculty members have departed.
(audience cheering)